there's a common theme that is that I've  noticed in this conversation and that is  that this most of this conversation has  revolved around women giving up sex at  different time intervals early mid late  and so on and we can see that the  denigration of society really revolves  around promiscuous sex and this is once  again again I'm a Muslim Islam Fetters  us and I believe men and women need  fettering not just women men also need  fettering as and controlling as well  because just as our brother Eddie  mentioned just now with scattergun you  know if I had it my way I'd marry one  woman because I I I've said this on one  of my podcasts before  one woman I only need one woman to love  and for her to love me that's enough  from a love perspective and a meaningful  relationship but I could have unlimited  sexual partners